the France has long ruled the world of
wine sure since at least the mid 20th
century the US has tried to match the
sophistication of French wines but it's
been a tough sell
when wine elves failed to convey
sophistication American winemakers
turned to classy British actors I like
if you don't recognize the thunderbird
label it's because the bottle is usually
covered with a brown paper bag this
champagne doesn't come from France even
the legendary Orson Welles couldn't
close the gap with the French dick to
these boozy outtakes confirm that Yankee
wines were good for just one thing
getting blissed American wines deserved
to be paired with food of equal
sophistication says French wine expert
Jean Noel for mo something like the
hamburger because the hamburger is not a
sophisticated dish in the sense of
cooking its preceeds macey hamburger
nation could never make wine like France
so it must have sounded like a cruel
joke when in 1976 a one of its kind
competition was arranged things there
was a tasting in pace that French wines
compared to Kenny funny wise mighty
France versus lowly California in a
blind taste test judge it entirely by
French wine connoisseurs they would
sample some of the best wine from each
location and vote for their favorite red
and their favourite white for most as
the French were confident even arrogant
it's going to be so easy only it wasn't
so easy the impossible happened
hamburger nation won top honors for both
red and white and France took a slap in
the face I was feeling like I was born
again Mike ger gets made the winning
White who was displayed at the
Smithsonian and his story was told in a
popular book the Paris tasting made him
a legend the back then even gergich
couldn't believe here
I said are you sure it's me how could
this American an immigrant who fled
communist Yugoslavia shocked the world
yes California's natural gifts and his
own talent were essential but so was
something else the freedom to create
wine his own way different when I came
from communism or was not freedom I have
used the American Opportunity gergich
was raised in a small village in Croatia
he developed a taste for wine at a very
young age to be honest my mom was
switching me from breast milk at the age
of two and half to wine and I like
Wenger gets arrived in California he was
nearly penniless but he knew he was in
the right place I already felt that
there is a kind of vibration in the air
that people are trying to compete one of
the great things that we do in America
and you hope it doesn't go away is we
have this great sense of adventure
Squire fried Ellen Sonoma County's Glen
lion winery
he says California's history of
freewheeling winemaking helped
revolutionize the craft we have a great
sense of let's try something new let's
try something different
it's different in France he says where
the government exerts control over many
aspects of winemaking they would have
tasters that come out from the
government for Moe was an official
taster for the French government not a
bad gig I go to the fill in shadows and
at taste and the wine passes so doesn't
pass he says the rich tradition that has
produced such revered wine also has a
downside the beauty of France is we have
a lot of punishment the podium of France
we have so many we cannot do anything
it's really like California progressed
from Thunderbird to gergiches
award-winning wine in just a couple of
decades the centuries-old chasm between
French and American winemakers was
closing quickly the French were
interested to understand what was going
on in California hamburger nation could
teach the French something about wine
how fun for fry del to ponder given what
he used to do for a living I was the
ronald mcdonald the second one that was
for the day I signed the contractors a
day that we put the house on the market
acting in commercials gave Riedel the
financial security to start his own
winery and he remembers how important
the Paris tasting was for the young
California industry and that course put
us on the map where no one could make
fun of us anymore as the younger brother
but I think it was the 80s where
everything started to get ramped up very
quickly we all started to get it up to
1980 America has never been the land of
get food or get wine so in 1984 mo
headed west my job was to come to
California for six months and it's
people who say to spy so what did the
wine spy find in California an
atmosphere of innovation and because of
that I make has been able to create any
things that have changed really the way
wine is made today innovations like
stainless steel tanks or malolactic
fermentation and processed gergich help
develop which counteracts tartness and
wine it's extremely difficult in France
compared to here that you always tied in
some more that are either government
also could include family who's not
having the rules and regulations that
they have in much of Europe and
particularly in France were able to
experiment Friday recalls his first
experiments first wines just sucked they
were not very good at all but you learn
first he planted Cabernet grapes but
eventually he discovered the climate was
a tad too cool for them he switched to
Syrah and since then his Sura has been
served in some of America's finest
restaurants what if he tried this grape
switcheroo in France you can't do it you
just can't do it in France would be
illegal for fry del to switch to Syrah
Pinot Noir or any other unapproved grape
if I want to grow Pinot Noir I want to
be able to grow Pinot Noir
too bad the French government decides
which grapes may be planted where the
government regulates everything from
alcohol content to pruning methods the
result that's harder for French
winemakers to innovate the fresh wine
industry is floundering France still
exports more wine but look at how
American exports have grown since the
1976 tasting the US and other new world
winemakers are gaining market share and
challenging French dominance
I think France has been lost a little
bit for a while former grew weary of
French rules and traditions I don't like
that weight of patient that on the top
of that they don't like people like me
who come with new ideas it doesn't go
with the establishment what was supposed
to be a six-month reconnaissance mission
has turned into nearly 30 years in a new
land for milk quit his job as an
official taster for the French
government and his co-founder of Chateau
Hotel he's now a celebrated wine
entrepreneur in California here I felt
free and I could be successful
and but why I've been doing here what
I've couldn't done in France but don't
forget about France for most says global
competition has forced French winemakers
to step up their game and that means
better wine for all of us for reason TV
on Ted Bolivar